welcome to this video playing mark the
great on the US what I can let's play
five and I try to play something
aggressive yet with e5 you can play em
no one not against this you can play
some interesting and gambits and so on
but not here yeah like can play a five
but that's really risky I mean really
risky me I don't do that sorry maybe
here there is Bishop before I think as
an interesting alternative to capturing
I don't really know I what I do know
after 95 there's castles I have okay
okay right is going for something
entirely different now that's that's
interesting that's an interesting
position it's not not not a boring one
okay i think d6 and taking on your fours
right
check
yeah that looks nice isn't this a nice
structure maybe white is some dynamic
plague coming but just from a structural
point of view this is a nice position
okay do I have anything better than then
retreating you're taking on c3 looks
looks wrong I mean I Bishop b2 and now
let's get this getting too much activity
this I guess yeah just retreat it's not
bad okay I can play Bishop F Bishop g4
now winning some time yeah it's probably
not too bad okay night f5 again and then
we'll create okay maybe castles first is
the more precise move Knight a5 Rukia
wow really now I cannot snot so fast not
so fast it's going to a form i give to
check on the aid king qd2 but that's a
disaster okay playing this yeah h3 was
really a bit term me a bit quickly this
decision I mean night f5 rook e8 is
pretty clear that that's coming yeah
yeah and now I have a very pleasant
choice can take on III with just a good
position or i can play rupee for winning
the Queen question is do I want to win
the Queen as the other continuation even
better my takes f take c3 it looks like
Swiss cheese but I don't have a direct
win so I probably should play rupee form
why don't win the Queen you can go to h2
I just spotted that yeah okay well
that's not really brilliant Queen g5 a
play h6 and distract you can get rook
and peace for the queen of course I
think this is better than Queen h2
actually Queen edge too i just take III
and slugs disastrous
yeah he didn't really develop many
pieces the sum is quite often a big
problem in double king porn openings of
one side neglect neglect development
then it get gets punished very hard
yeah it's difficult to even sacrifice
the Queen in a decent way let's say
Queenie 494 H takes g4 there is night
xe3 and again we have the Swiss cheese
pawn structure now this is another way
to try the second night III actually
could be better first and then take on
f4 I ask no way to save the queen anyway
where where where where would the Queen
go I threaten this discovered two checks
like C to G to everywhere so probably
Queen takes a form or take some only
three SS played anyway
yeah a tree was suicidal almost
yeah if we took him like three seconds
and now he's thinking for ages when it's
already by far too late King Jack Webb
the right the Queen resigns yeah now
that's really funny typical those the
size of mistakes we are played there
really quickly and when it's totally
over it it's time to think for form for
most people here three seconds 4 h3
which loses yeah this is why I thought
that maybe castles is a bit bit bit
sneaky em because all night f5 he will
obviously spot that the queen is
attacked however the computer gives this
as easily winning because i have also
Queenie 7 I see GAD assists and then
this is better because it's winning
instantly the point is that here what is
white smooth Kingda to can try that but
there is an ID form Jack under that's
not good there's also this move quite
embarrassing winning the Queen check and
what about this there is the smooth the
computer is really merciless this in
tactical positions again winning the
Queen so then it was better but ok after
after that it seems whites only move not
to loose inside these f3 and this is
really ugly and this is some yeah yeah
this is the game and it wasn't nice
register it just still the carnage this
is a relatively best according to the
engine and it's a minus 5 I wonder ever
can take here now probably
easy as to just drop back weak weak
everything's we can then I think then
the most critical continuation after
Bishop before as night xe5 i'm not
mistaken then there is the old line 94
which is I think bad due to Quincy form
very wide line but and I think it's not
really working but black hand castle
which is interesting trying to play for
quick development with ruki aid this has
been played by mohmmad yar off if i'm
not mistaken alright thanks for watching